yeah but I think  like I I have a group of friends right  and when I walk into the room with a  group of friends I know immediately  who's going to get the most attention  from the guys it's it's not me right I  have like a friend who's like very very  attractive and I know when I walk into a  room with her like the guys talk to her  first because like girls you can kind of  just feel it but I almost wonder when I  hear like and I hear this from girls a  lot like I'm a 10 I'm a 10 I'm a 10.  um if that's not like rooted in reality  because attractiveness like there's  numbers behind it whether it's just your  results in the world or your dating app  data or  the like the type of guys you can get